bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur ce
live on est à la fois en live sur ma
chaîne youtube sur la chaîne youtube de
l'ina sur la page facebook de l'ina et
sur ma page facebook
aude gg donc on est en live à peu près
partout donc je me présente pour ceux
qui ne connaîtraient pas je m'appelle
ogoni goubert dit au djé djé je suis
actrice et créatrice de vidéos et en
l'occurrence je fais ce live en
partenariat avec l'ina pour vous
présenter la série la nouvelle série
documentaire qui s'appelle virage ina et
vous expliquer un petit peu son contenu
et y aura aussi des questions réponses
donc n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
et on est ensemble pour au moins une
petite heure alors virage inas est une
série documentaire qui est composé de
cinq grands épisodes qui sont qui vont
retracer toutes les lois et les
mouvements qui ont jalonné le droit des
femmes au 20e siècle et donc je serai à
la fois la chroniqueuse qui retrace les
grandes lois et je parlerai à côté des
archives de l'ina pour retracer tout
c'est tout ces événements et ces moments
marquants et faire aussi un parallèle
avec aujourd'hui où on en est par
rapport à ces lois qui ont 40 50 70 ans
et savoir où on en est aujourd'hui dans
notre société actuelle on regarde un
extrait bas alors commençons à rentrer
directement dans le vif du sujet ça va
détendre tout le monde surtout moi et
puis comme ça après je vous explique un
peu mieux la série d'amc a donné le
droit de vote aux femmes
à je ne sais que c'est un 1945 21
octobre mais je ne pourrais pas vous
dire qui ma foi la peau leur premier
chez blum général de gaulle quand je
dirais pétain peut-être en sauriol
employant 3 août et je ne suis pas au
courant parce que j'ai pas de télévision
[Musique]
et bien mesdames c'est au général de
gaulle que vous devez le droit de vote
le 21 avril 1944 en effet réuni sous sa
présidence à alger le comité français de
libération nationale prenait cette
décision après avis favorable de
l'assemblée consultative le général mais
pas uniquement
je pense que la politique féminine qui a
été menée a été importante
donc cette promotion féminine avec un
certain retard sur les pays voisins
la france vit alors un jour historique
pour la première fois depuis toujours le
coeur de gras millions de moi c'était le
29 avril 1945
voilà ça c'est l extrait en extrait de
l'épisode sur la conquête du droit de
vote
alors comment est venue cette idée c'est
simple il ya deux ans j'ai créé un
programme qui s'appelle virago qui est
sur ma chaîne youtube qui sont des
chroniques historiques humoristique et
féministe sur les femmes qui ont changé
le monde et dont on a peu voire jamais
entendu parler et sur ce procédé je suis
à la fois une chroniqueuse qui raconte
des faits biographique historique est à
la fois un personnage dans un cadre qui
s'anime et qui retrace la vie et le
parcours de ces femmes et de fait il ya
eu il ya il ya un an un appel à projets
de l'ina de l'institut national de
l'audiovisuel qui proposait en fait de
au créateur de mettre en valeur leurs
archives
puisque lina il faut savoir que c'est
quand même une banque de 2 millions
d'heures d'archivés et donc pour les
faire découvrir pour ressortir des
choses que les gens n'ont pas forcément
vu qu'ils sont inédites proposait à à
tout un chacun
finalement de créer du contenu donc moi
je leur ai proposé une déclinaison de
mon programme qui s'appelle virage ina
et donc où je suis toujours une
chroniqueuse mais avec des archives de
l'ina au lieu d'être un personnage dans
le cadre est d'ailleurs bain pour ceux
qui n'ont pas vu virago et qu'ils
connaissent pas virago on peut regarder
le teaser de la chaîne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça c'était le teaser de virago
donc le programme que j'ai créé et qui
est sur ma chaîne d'ailleurs pour ceux
qui auront reconnu le teaser est un
petit clin d'oeil au générique de la
série the young pop qui se passe
uniquement dans un milieu d'hommes
donc c'était c'était un petit clin
d'oeil référence puisque ma série virago
se passe dans un musée imaginaire qui
qui qui seraient consacrées à des femmes
extraordinaires et est donc voilà donc
la série aujourd'hui qui est sur ma
chaîne comporte 26 épisodes que j'ai
fait avec une équipe derrière moi mais
on a fait ça un peu tout seul avec les
moyens du bord comme on a pu donc on a
on a beaucoup produit et et c'est comme
ça que du coup j'ai eu envie de le
décliner et d'aller sur virage ina eh
bien regardez un extrait de virago pour
ceux qui connaissent pas comme ça ça
permet de parce que je rappelle quand
même qu'on est en live sur ma chaîne et
sur mon facebook donc ça normalement si
vous me suivez a priori vous connaissez
le programme qui me tient quand même à
coeur et que je porte depuis deux ans
mais pour tous ceux qui sont sur la
chaîne de l'ina peut-être vous n'avez
pas encore découvert et je vous invite à
le faire incessamment sous peu
mais du coup on va regarder un extrait
virago effectivement après quelques mois
de dépression où elle voit arriver un
paquet de galères financières elles
déjouent un par un les pièges tendus par
les créanciers de son défunt mari ait
réussi à récupérer les sommes qui lui
sont dues
oui là c'est très résumé mais ça a duré
14 ans quand même bien éduqué l'esprit
brillant et désormais soulagés elle
dispose alors de temps libre pour lire
et écrire
je compose un grand nombre de textes et
de poèmes d'amour à l'intention de mon
défunt mari
juste pour le plaisir c'est écrit en bas
la cour et tout particulièrement le duc
de bourgogne philippe le hardi qui lui
propose d'écrire la vie de son frère
mort peu de temps avant le roi charles 5
lesage livre qu'elle lui il livre en
1404 le livre des faits et bonnes moeurs
du sage roi à charlo 5
c'est donc à partir de cet ouvrage
qu'elle démarre véritablement sa
carrière de femme de lettres homme de
lettres on diffame de l'être maintenant
c'est mieux
voilà ça c'est par exemple l'épisode sur
christine de pisan qui est quand même
une motrice qui écrit un manifeste en
1405 pour le contre l'insécurité des
femmes dans l'espace public donc c'est
quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à cette époque là et
donc tous les épisodes sont sur ce mode
là donc parfois j'ai des invités
parfois je chronique avec des vidéastes
de youtube vulgarisateur et parfois
j'invite aussi des des amis comédienne à
venir incarner les rôles dans le cadre à
côté de la chroniqueuse voilà n'hésitez
pas à poser des questions sur ce live
parce que là on vous reçoit en grande
pompe
on est presque dans mon salon enfin
quasi mais avait beaucoup de caméras
quand même par rapport à mon salon mais
ça n'empêche pas que je reçoive aux
questions donc n'hésitez pas à les poser
et on va me les envoyer alors
d'autres épisodes de virago et bien pour
l'instant virago donc ça en deux ans
j'ai sorti 26 épisodes c'est très lourd
à créer et à produire parce que de la
recherche documentaire aux effets
spéciaux je mets des semaines voire des
mois à sortir un épisode et on est sept
à travailler bénévolement sur ce projet
puisque j'ai sorti ce projet sans
production sans financement sans network
j'ai eu l'aide du cncm un moment donné
pour faire quelques épisodes mais à un
moment donné cette aide prend fin donc
pour l'instant la série je les jeux les
mises en stand by où je les jeux les
arrêter là sur ces 26 épisodes qui sont
déjà des très beaux produits dont je
suis extrêmement fier donc j'ai envie
qu'ils vivent un petit peu qu'ils soient
partagées qu'ils soient vus et puis
peut-être si je trouve un vrai
financement ou une façon de une façon de
perdurer dans un modèle économique qui
ne soit pas juste d'exploiter les gens
qui travaillent avec moi je n'hésiterai
pas à en faire plein d'autres en tout
cas c'est pas l'inspiration qui manquent
premièrement parce que la communauté et
les le premier contributeur à faire
grossir la liste des potentiels virago
de qui parlait et et aussi il ya le il
ya le fait qu'on a constitué au fur et à
mesure de nos recherches de discussion
de
de l'alimentation de la communauté un
fichier excel où il ya 400 femmes
donc j'ai de quoi faire 400 épisodes
jusqu'à mai 81 ans
donc si un jour je trouve le financement
ou la possibilité de le faire de façon
pérenne
évidemment je continuerai ce projet mais
pour l'instant du coup j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire une déclinaison
c'est ça qui est plutôt chouette et
c'est ça dont on vient à parler ce soir
rémy j'ai petite question j'ai pas bien
entendu à ce que le droit des femmes en
france où est-ce qu'on s'intéressera
aussi aux archives qui concerne
l'international
ah oui d'accord alors en fait le les
cinq épisodes avec lesquels on lance la
série sont sur vraiment le toutes les
lois qui ont jalonné le droit des femmes
en france en l'occurrence
sauf qu'en fait par exemple si on prend
le droit de vote on ne peut pas parler
de l'avènement du droit de vote sans
parler des suffragettes ou dès que ce
soit en angleterre ou aux états unis
donc forcément on fait un lien avec
l'international et par exemple sur un
épisode sur la loi veil on va aussi
faire un petit peu le tour de ce qui se
passe dans les pays voisins
antoine morel quand pourra-t-on voir le
premier épisode est le premier épisode
sera en ligne ce soir c'est je pars donc
je suis extrêmement contente parce que
ça fait un an qu'on travaille sur ce
projet et je suis fier de ce projet que
je trouve beau et important est donc le
premier épisode qui sera sur la loi veil
donc pour l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse soir en ligne juste après le
live notice de parents ça chouette
pseudo presque un peu flippant du coup
puisque je me sens surveiller comment tu
choisis les femmes que tu veux présenter
eh ben c'est une excellente question
alors dans virago il ya plusieurs
paramètres qui rentrent en compte s'il
ya le coup de coeur la paix à la femme
que j'ai découverte ou qu'on a découvert
avec mon co auteur qui s'appelle adrien
rey baudot qui est aussi le co auteur de
virgin a donc soit nos coups de coeur
soit aussi de la construction de
diffusion c'est à dire que sur une
journée de tournage par exemple quand je
vais tourner quatre épisodes
donc je vais traiter de quatre
personnages et qui vont être diffusés au
fur et à mesure donc l'intérêt n'est pas
de faire quatre anglaise du 19e siècle
dont j'essaie de varier et d'aller
chercher dans toutes les cultures toutes
les époques tous les milieux parce que
c'est ça aussi le l'adn de virago c'est
de prendre des femmes qui ont transcendé
leur milieu social leur religion leur
époque des contraintes
politique pour faire des choses
extraordinaires mais partout dans le
monde de montrer que c'est pas juste
en fait c'est pas parce qu'on ne les
connais pas qu'elles n'ont pas fait des
choses extraordinaires partout dans le
monde et à toutes les époques
c'est quoi la différence entre virago et
virages inaba il ya une différence
majeure donc virago on se documente
énormément on écrit un texte et on fixe
yonne le personnage donc au général je
prends quand même des références
extrêmement historique pour que ce soit
pour le maquillage pour les costumes on
va vraiment faire un travail de
recherche extrêmement précis mais le
personnage que j'interprète est presque
de la fiction en tout cas parfois soit
il se rapproche vraiment d'une personne
parce qu'on a eu sa représentation on a
vu des vidéos des photos soit la
personne d'une époque beaucoup trop
éloignés et dans ces cas là c'est un peu
le fantasme de ce que moi j'ai envie de
représenter la différence avec un virage
ina c'est tout simple c'est que
j'imaginais on traite avec de la vraie
archives on traite avec les vrais
personnages c'est à dire que je n'aurais
pas pu faire aussi bien
simone veil sur ma chaîne en faisant du
virago camps l'ayant vraiment avec sa
parole avec son aura avec son
intelligence
comme je lai là dans les épisodes de
virage il a donc c'est ça aussi la
grande valeur ajoutée
ce sont les archives de l'ina ce sont
des du témoignage c'est vraiment ces
archives c'est à la fois les archives
très rigolote et à la fois c'est quand
même du patrimoine c'est quand même
notre histoire qui est qui et qui est la
mémoire vivante de tous que de tout ce
qui nous a amenés aujourd'hui à la
société dans laquelle on vit
donc forcément c'est ça la majeure la
différence l'amiable la plus grande
j'espère que vous voyez la mouche qui
n'arrête pas de passer devant l'écran ce
que moi je n'arrête pas de l'avoir c'est
extrêmement perturbant des têtes elle
veut participer au live à la loi voilà
du coup j'espère que j'avais fini ma
phrase sur suis pas sûr on regarde un
extrait de virages inaba avec plaisir
regardons un extrait de virigina pour
vous il n'ya pas de métier au masculin
non comme je pense qu'un apport fine
c'est donc au niveau de l'état
comme au niveau de la société que tout
ça doit changer de nouveaux codes et de
nouvelles habitudes à prendre
c'est à dire que nous vivons dans une
société
où seuls ceux reconnus comme
travailleurs les gens qui ont un salaire
ou une entreprise ou qui ont pignon sur
rue c'est à dire que toutes les
situations des femmes qui pour des
raisons diverses qu après tout qui les
regardent ou qui regardent à la famille
puisque la décision est prise en famille
se sont arrêtés d'avoir un travail
salarié pour rester chez elle et se
consacrer à telle ou telle ou telle
tâche les enfants peut être aidé le mari
et c'est l'extraordinaire injustice
c'est qu'elles deviennent invisibles
elle ne compte plus
voilà ça c'est l'épisode par exemple sur
la loi roudy qui était pour l'égalité
salariale et donc il ya qui a mené toute
une campagne pour cette égalité est
aujourd'hui en 2019 dans la plupart des
métiers on sait que les femmes gagnent
en moyenne en moyenne 24% de moins que
les hommes
donc c'est ça aussi qui est intéressant
avec virgin a c'est qu'on regarde d'où
partent les lois de quel constat est on
regarde les gens qui les ont portés et
on voit où on est arrivés ou pas arrivé
donc c'est ça qui est très intéressant
enrichissant et moi ce que je trouve
génial aussi faire là où je suis très
heureuse c'est qu'évidemment quand je
démarre sur ces sujets je ne suis pas
historienne je suis pas journaliste je
ne je pars du principe que je ne sais
rien donc je rentre dans cette
documentation je découvre je découvre
cette femme yvette roudy en l'occurrence
que moi je ne connaissais pas parce que
je suis très jeune
probablement mais je suis pas sûr que
les gens en tout cas l'inconscient
collectif connaissent son nom et c'est
ça que je trouve extraordinaire parce
que cette femme quand on les écoute
parler quand vous verrez l'épisode de
virages ina il ya une telle présence un
charisme une conviction de défendre des
choses qui dans une époque et encore une
fois faut toujours replacer les choses
dans leur contexte
dans une époque qui était pas du tout
acquise à cette cause donc c'est ça que
je trouve très passionnant alors julie
vincent quelle femme aurais tu aimé
rencontrer
baj
évidemment j'aurais voulu rencontrer
simone veil
et je suis toujours extrêmement ému et
dans toutes les archives que vous verrez
dans le premier épisode qui sort ce soir
j'espère que vous serez autant que moi
impressionné par la force qu'elle dégage
même quand c'est des images filmées que
vous allez être derrière votre écran
d'ordinateur
elle mois elle elle dégage un truc qui
me donne la chair de poule de partout
tellement cette femme a un passé
absolument tragique et une force de vie
de conviction et c'est assez c'est assez
exceptionnel donc je pense que j'aurais
voulu aimer enfin j'aurais aimé
rencontrer simone veil anouchka 186
bonjour petite question penses-tu
traiter des sujets d'actualité ben c'est
là où c'est incroyable c'est que
l'histoire pour moi l'histoire avec un
grand h est clair notre actualité donc
en fait à chaque fois qu'on parle d'un
sujet d'histoire ô combien ils trouvent
un écho aujourd'hui par exemple en tout
simplement aujourd'hui le premier
épisode de sueur sur la loi veil et
résonne terriblement puisqu'on sait ce
qui se passe en ce moment en alabama où
ils viennent de voter la loi la plus
régressives concernant lives et j'ai au
texas
il parle de 2
the la peine de mort à des femmes qui
auraient qui auraient pratiqué un
avortement
voilà donc donc c'est on ne peut plus
d'actualité puisque si je peux me
permettre de deux cités simone de
beauvoir
elle disait il suffira d'une crise
politique économique ou religieuse pour
que les droits des femmes soient remis
en cause
vous ne devez vous devez ces droits ne
sont jamais à qui vous devez rester
vigilant de votre vie durant
voilà c'est ça la citation est en fait
on voit que là on va regarder des
combats pour pour le droit de vote pour
les vg pour l'égalité tout simplement
sociale ou salariales et on voit que
finalement ce sont toujours des
questions aujourd'hui qu'on se pose dans
la société qu'on voit en plein débat
dans les mets dans les médias alors que
ça ne devrait pas être un sujet ça ne
devrait pas être un débat puisque les
femmes font partie façon à 53% de la
population
c'est un jeu à san san n'a échappé à
personne que c'était des êtres humains a
à peu près exactement comme les autres
et est donc évidemment que ça traite
d'actualité
parce par le biais de l'histoire et je
trouve ça par ailleurs j'espère que je
suis pas trop confuse et capter ce que
je veux dire mais je je trouve que
parfois une petite piqûre de rappel de
par où sont passés ces femmes là par
exemple
là il ya des élections c'est vrai que
moi en regardant le droit de vote fin
quand je vais voter je me dis bon bah je
vote c'est normal mais quand je regarde
l'épisode enfin quand on a créé
l'épisode du droit de vote
on se rend compte de ce que ça a été
comme conquête et comme bataille pour
l'obtenir
donc je trouve ça toujours intéressant
d'avoir des petites piqûres de rappel à
ce niveau là oh merde alors excellent
jeu de mots combien de temps prend
combien de temps va pardon pour ce pôle
irs combien de temps prend t-il à écrire
oui d'accord à écrire au tourner un
épisode alors je crois que le plus long
en fait c'est l'écriture
donc on est deux à l'écriture adrien rey
bodo et moi est en fait l'écriture c'est
pas simplement c'est pas simplement posé
poser des mots sur un ordinateur c'est
vraiment se nourrir de loi que parfois
on ne connaît pas chercher un contexte
historique politique sociale aussi
puisque
on peut pas regarder des archives ou
écrire un épisode qui se passe un siècle
avant avec notre prisme et avec notre
notre idée aujourd'hui de ce qu'on pense
politiquement socialement
donc on est obligé vraiment de se
remettre dans un contexte qu'on n'a pas
vécu pour ensuite essayer de redonner
toutes les connaissances qu'on a acquise
et surtout moi j'ai un quand même une
exigence sur ma chaîne youtube
c'est vraiment de ne faire aucun aucune
concession aux faits historiques
donc il faut que nos sources soit
extrêmement recouper qu'on soit
extrêmement précis et exigeant sur ce
qu'on dit et qu'il n'y ait pas de choses
approximatives donc toutes ces choses là
ça prend du temps
en écriture ça prend du temps de
maturation aussi pour que l'épisode soit
digest compréhensible et ensuite
et ensuite quand ça entre en tournage
c'est quasiment le tournage est
quasiment la chose qui prend le moins de
temps puisque ça veut dire que le texte
quand ils arrivent en tournage a été
extrêmement travaillée retravaillée
retravailler extrêmement solide et après
à la post production qui prend aussi
beaucoup de temps puisqu'on je pense que
vous verrez c'est ce que j'avais envie
de mettre sur youtube aussi c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit pas toujours
ces dons c'est de pouvoir mettre à la
fois du fonds est à la fois une forme et
travailler un peu un objet qui soit
esthétique hanna ll
qu'espérez-vous apporté à la jeunesse à
la fois féminine et masculine en
présentant virage ina alors je me
permettrais pas de dire que j'apporte
quelque chose à la jeunesse ce serait
beaucoup trop sur mes petites épaules en
revanche si je peux à la fois
transmettre
moi ce que j'ai appris ce qui me
passionne ce que je trouve incroyable et
si je peux le transmettre au maximum que
ce soit aux jeunes et aux moins jeunes
d'ailleurs parce que je me considère
plus tout à fait comme très jeune et il
ya plein de choses que je ne savais pas
donc si je peux partager cette chose-là
qui a un qui est aussi une volonté de
de mettre beaucoup d'optimisme et de
montrer des choses positives et
extraordinaires qui ont bougé et qui
peuvent encore bouger et de ne pas être
que dans un constat négatif au contraire
de se dire voilà c'est possible des
femmes ont pris la parole des femmes ont
pris le pouvoir pour faire avancer la
société
parce que c'est pas faire avancer que
les femmes d'ailleurs moi je considère
qu'une une société qui n'est pas
parfaitement équitable ne peut pas
fonctionner donc quand ça va bien pour
les femmes ça va bien pour toute la
société
donc voilà donc je j'ai un optimisme et
j'ai appris des choses et c'est ça que
j'aimerais bien pouvoir retransmettre
voilà c'est le principe même de un peu
de la vulgarisation ce que j'essaye de
faire sur youtube à l'appui de questions
et a pu rien ils ont bougé ils sont tous
endormis ont l'impression que suis seul
dans le salon mais non il ya des gens
derrière quel sujet a dû traiter et
pourquoi alors dans virage ina en
l'occurence j'avais une petite
contrainte de faire de démarrer la série
avec cinq épisodes donc évidemment
j'avais pléthore de sujets à traiter
on a choisi on a choisi des choses qui
nous paraissaient extrêmement marquantes
et fondatrice au 20e siècle et surtout
on a aussi essayé d'aller d'aller
chercher d'aidé pour faire aussi un lien
avec la cousinade virago des lois qui
ont été vraiment porté par une incarnant
tu donc le droit de vote on le découvre
à travers le prisme de louise weiss
l'ibg à travers simone veil l'égalité
sociétale à travers françoise giroud
yvette roudy pour le pour l'égalité
salariale et on a un autre épisode aussi
qu'ils sont sur les grands mouvements du
mlf pourquoi il ya eu cet avènement de
mouvement et en l'occurrence le mlf
c'est à travers anne zelensky comment
choisis-tu des extraits alors voilà
ben là c'est là où le gros travail de
deux virages ina nous a pris énormément
de temps et on ya passé presque ben ça
fait presque un an qu'on a démarré le
projet c'est parce que on choisit on a
choisi nos sujets on s'est documenté
dessus ensuite on a fait appel à des
documentalistes à l'ina qui nous qui
permettent d'aller chercher plein
d'extrait de les les qui ont été
répertoriés et de nous les envoyer
et là on regarde des heures et des
heures et des heures d'archivés on a
regardé des centaines d'heures
d'archivés pour attraper la petite
phrase qui va dialoguer et qui va nous
faire avancer la narration de l'épisode
parce que donc c'est faire la fois une
série documentaire mais c'est quand même
une petite narration avec un petit fil
conducteur et un dialogue entre les
archives et la chroniqueuse comment
construire eu un épisode
ben voilà en l'occurrence c'est ça c'est
apprendre à prendre les lois l'histoire
prendre les extraits et les trier et
avalé un nombre d'image incroyable et
ensuite construire le dialogue au fur et
à mesure pour essayer d'être de raconter
leur sont des épisodes qui font entre
sept et huit minutes
donc c'est quand même un format long
pour par rapport à ce que je fais sur
virago mais pour quand même traversé
sans faire trop de raccourcis et pouvoir
quand même avoir une idée globale
évidemment ça sera jamais exhaustif mais
moi j'espère aussi qu'une fois que les
gens se soient intéressés un sujet il
est en vie par eux-mêmes d'aller
découvrir ces sujets là et d'aller se
renseigner
regardons un extrait avec joie les
arguments des anti ivg ramène souvent le
débat autour de la question de la vie à
venir sans prendre en compte celle de la
mère et des difficultés qu'elle peut
rencontrer comme l'avortement dessus
c'est absolument incroyable on voit que
sont les hommes qui font les lois parce
que s'il leur arrive est quelquefois
d'avoir les problèmes des femmes et
comprendrait plus facilement qu'il faut
absolument ce problème se règle très
très rapide
alors c'est avec autant de finesse que
d'intelligence que simone veil va
présenter son projet à l'assemblée
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
aucune jamais ça c'est un extrait du
premier épisode qui sera en ligne ce
soir après le live et moi j'en ai j'en
ai toujours la chair de poule parce que
cette femme qui est folle imaginer là on
a le champ sur elle mais le contrechamp
c'est une assemblée exclusivement quand
ceux constitués d'hommes
enfin quasiment exclusivement et et elle
porte son sujet
d'une façon exceptionnelle donc voilà ça
ça fait partie des extraits que j'aime
beaucoup d'ailleurs dans la série quel
livre féministe conseillerais tu
ralalala chop chop
après je suis embêté avec j'aimerais
bien que j'aimerais bien que le super
ministre ne soit plus un sujet
j'adorerais que ce ne soit plus un sujet
mais je pense qu'une pour moi la bible
absolue à avoir lu de base c'est king
kong théorie de virginie despentes boit
de l'eau c'est pour moi ou c'est annonce
est un pseudo verrons-nous seulement
cinq épisodes de virages in house bien
une nouvelle salve d'épisodes sera
produite dans les mois à venir
1 mais alors donc là vous verrez cinq
épisodes en qui seront diffusés toutes
les semaines tous les jeudis soirs
j'espère qu'on en fera d'autres ça
dépendra de comment c'est plébiscité par
part vous par les gens du public si vous
aimez si vous commenter si vous le
partagez
si ça vous plaît surtout et si si ça
fonctionne j'espère qu'on en fera
d'autres avec jean clarisse gérant
bonjour de comment avez vous choisi les
sujets des épisodes de virages inard
merci pour tout ce que vous faites
ben c'est ce que je disais un petit peu
avant dans le live c'est que je les ai
on les a choisis comme en tout cas selon
nous les vraiment les grandes choses les
plus marquantes du xxème siècle il y en
a plein d'autres mais à un moment donné
faire les faire un choix
c'est dire que nous au départ on était
parti sur huit ou dix épisodes donc on
avait plein d'autres moments marquants
du 20e siècle
et puis on a fait cette sélection est
aussi en fonction de ces femmes qui les
incarnent
salma benji pourquoi le nom virage inaba
c'est tout simplement un jeu de mots
extrêmement subtile et c'est aussi la
contraction de virago donc le programme
dont est décliné la série et dîna pour
les archives de l'ina est alors du coup
du coup pourquoi virago parce que du
coup c'est une question qui revient
souvent donc je vais le redire aussi ici
virago c'est un terme extrêmement
péjoratif qui désigne ou une femme aux
allures masculines et c'est aujourd'hui
presque une insulte sauf que dans sa
définition originelle c'est une femme
courageuse brave une héroïne une guerre
hier et c'est la définition originelle
que j'avais envie de rétablir
c'est un terme qui a glissé au 19e
siècle d'ailleurs puisque il faut savoir
que le 19e siècle a fait beaucoup de mal
aux femmes et donc voilà donc si je peux
rétablir l'autre définition je serais
heureuse la séquence préférait faut
alors j'ai beaucoup de séquences
préférées d'un virage in a évidemment eu
des épisodes fort et dur et et qui
traitent de sujets graves mais en même
temps il ya quelques petites pépites
d'art shiv khera complètement hors temps
je pense par exemple à cette pub qui a
été qui a été vraiment qui a été diffusé
à la télévision donc dans les années 70
contre l'inégalité entre les hommes et
les femmes
l'inégalité salariale et c'est yvette
roudy qui justement qui atteint 42 cet
épisode là qui avait fait qui avait
commandé ce spot télévisé et ça c'est
complètement magique je sais pas si vous
sont là si on peut le regarder mais ça
c'est insensé
pour ça elle va même aller jusqu'à
diffuser des spots de publicité à la
télévision non arrêté dans la vie
professionnelle les femmes en trop
d'obstacles à franchir formation
restreinte
débouchés moureu
allaire inégaux ce n'est pas normal ça
doit changer non arrêtez avec des gens
plein de convictions et beaucoup de
sourcils moi je t'ai hurler de rire
c'était comment de travailler avec les
archives de l'ina basse travail et que
les archives de l'ina c'est un vortex il
faut savoir que l' avantage dans virago
c'est concret de toutes parts le
dialogue donc si on a envie de faire
dire ça on fait dire ça là il faut
traiter avec de la matière existantes
et puis surtout c'est un vortex est à
dire que je sais pas si vous êtes déjà
promené sur le site de l'ina mais quand
vous tapez ben j'aime bien les lampes de
chevet je tape lampe de chevet vous
allez vraiment tapé pas ça serait
absurde mais je tape ça je vais tomber
sur un nombre de vidéos qui vont
entraîner d'une vidéo à une autre et
c'est une espèce de vortex et quand on
plonge la main en fait on en ressort 24
heures après s'en être alimentés et donc
c'est un peu ce qu'on a vécu pendant
plusieurs mois
avec mon co auteur a travaillé dans les
archives de l'ina et avec le réalisateur
aussi david tabourier qui est aussi le
réalisateur de vire à gauche parce que
je travaille toujours tant qu'à faire
avec la même équipe parce que c'est
meilleur tout simplement
et pareil david tabourier quand il est
venu après en post-production aussi donc
il a réalisé les épisodes mais quand il
est venu en post-production il a quand
même été recherché aussi de l'art
chiffres pour alimenter et pour pour
parfois illustrés certains propos qui
n'avaient pas forcément d'image
correspondante
et ça aussi du coup ça nous ré emmène à
repartir pendant des jours et des jours
dans un flou d'image incroyable et on
n'en a jamais fini
des projets à venir bas plein de projets
à venir déjà j'avoue que je suis quand
même très fier et très contente que
cette série voit le jour vraiment c'est
un projet qui me qui me tient à coeur et
qui et qui j'espère ben je me répète
mais j'espère vous plaira autant qu'à
moi parce que je suis fier de le porter
il ya aussi le livre virago qui est en
cours d'écriture et là qui présentera
une soixantaine de portraits mais ça
c'est plutôt pour l'année prochaine est
évidemment bien sûr ce que là on ne
parle que de youtube et de et de et de
séries virago et virages ina mais je
suis évidemment en fiction et je fais
toujours mon métier d'actrice et je suis
aussi bien à la télévision qu'au cinéma
très prochainement dans des choses
formidables mais je dirai tout sur mes
réseaux sociaux obligent et n'hésitez
pas à y aller
alicia m
serait-il envisageable de faire le
portrait d'hommes qui ont lutté pour la
parité il doit bien y en avoir
absolument il y en a plein et c'est un
sujet qui revient souvent avec mon co
auteur c'est rigolo que tu veux que tu
parles de ça parce qu'on n'a vraiment
envie aussi de de mettre ça en lumière
parce que pour nous et pour moi ce n'est
pas du tout une question de femmes le
droit des femmes c'est une question de
société c'est une question qui
appartient à tout le monde
et évidemment que les hommes peuvent
intervenir et ont le droit à la parole
là dessus et qu'il n'ya pas faut pas
envisager de lutter contre une exclusion
en en faisant une autre donc au
contraire moi j'ai envie aussi
d'entendre plus les hommes parler de ça
et effectivement on a beaucoup réfléchi
alors dans quel format
puisqu'aujourd'hui virago est un peu en
stand by faute de moyens très clairement
mais mais c'est vraiment une idée qui
nous titille et je pense que dans le
livre il y aura faut le noter ça dans le
livre il faudra qu'on le fasse au faniel
un jour un virago ou un virage in a avec
une figure féminine que tu interview en
live ce serait envisageable mais f
ça serait incroyable mais s'il ya
plusieurs difficultés avec ça c'est que
évidemment c'est toujours plus difficile
puisque mon idée aussi de virago c'est
de mettre en lumière de rendre hommage
de mettre sur un piédestal quelqu'un
c'est toujours plus difficile de l'avoir
à côté en le faisant
parce que la personne pour être
potentiellement un peu dérangée par ça
il ya aussi le fait que virago c'est
quand même c'est aussi un exercice
d'actrice donc pour moi d'interpréter
tous ces personnages et virages ina
comme ça démarre on ne sait pas ce que
ça peut donner après mais franchement
tout est possible boris j quelles sont
les images d'aujourd'hui qu'il te
plairait d'utiliser comme archives dans
disant ah là là elle est incroyable
cette question bah je vois là sur le
premier je veux dire le premier truc qui
me vient à l'esprit
j'adorerais que dans dix ans on utilise
des archives de toutes les vidéos où on
voit les océans plein de plastique en
faisant vous rendez compte il ya dix ans
il y avait du plastique dans l'océan
c'est insensé et y avait pu plus
d'animaux puis on allait tous mourir
c'est fou alors que maintenant tout va
mieux et et on respire hyper bien oui
collège et chez stage et plan b pearson
a fait réponse mais ce comme c'est un
sujet qui nous trouvent tous dans la
tête en ce moment as-tu réfléchi à la
question de mettre tout les épisodes à
la portée des jeunes adolescents et
adolescentes dans le système scolaire
j'aurais aimé savoir et j'ai pas la fin
des questions
j'aurais aimé le savoir peut-être ça se
termine comme ça alors en l'occurrence
celle avantage de youtube et c'est aussi
c'est l'avantagé la contrainte pour moi
c'est que youtube c'est c'est un contenu
gratuit et libre d'accès donc c'est
aussi pour ça que moi du coup j'ai pas
de financement pour le faire et donc
pour l'instant que le modèle économique
ne peut pas être viable comme ça mais le
fait est que cette à la portée de tous
donc c'est possible de le partager
d'ailleurs je sais qu'il ya des parents
qui partagent avec leurs enfants et l'
inverse des enfants des jeunes gens qui
partagent avec leurs parents et aussi
que c'est beaucoup utilisé par des profs
parce que j'ai beaucoup de retours de
professeurs qui l'utilisent dans classe
donc ça pour moi c'est c'est évidemment
une immense fierté et tant mieux si ça
peut être un peu vu le mot de la fin
déjà et bien et bien le mot de la fin
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce live donc
sur les pages facebook les chaînes
youtube
j'espère que ça vous a donné envie de
regarder la série en tout cas autant
envie
que moi j'ai eu de la sphère de la
construire et de vous la proposer ce
soir vous allez donc à la fin du live
découvrir le premier épisode sur la loi
veil et et bien sûr je pourrais répondre
à plus de questions et n'hésitez pas à
me contacter sur les réseaux sociaux à
taux de gégé sur facebook sur twitter
sur instagram et j'essaierai de répondre
au plus grand nombre et puis n'hésitez
pas aussi à commenter les épisodes et à
faire des retours et à dire à l'ina que
c'est super et qu'ils ont envie d'en
voir plein d'autres et et puis voilà
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi ce live
merci à golden ya studio et alina de
l'avoir produit est d'avoir permis que
je sois pas avec une pauvre petite
webcam et des nouilles lyophilisée dans
mon salon et qu'on fasse ça et qu'on
vous reçoivent en grande pompe à l'image
de cette série qui est qui et jolie est
importante c'est fini